GOT IT!
GIANNIS TIES THE
K.D. FOR THE LEAD.
DOUBLED.
OUT TO IRVING.
HERE COMES GIANNIS. POINT. FOR E
GIANNIS' JUMPSHOT , WOULD YOU
TAKE THAT?
YES, PLEASE.
HARRIS, THE STILL.
A CHANCE TO
>> KATE:-BOARD GAME
OFF THE MARK.
EMBIID, THE COMES.
GEORGE PRIMED TO KEEP IN FRONT..
THAT WILL GET POOLE TO THE LINE.
AND A CHANCE TO GIVE GOL
40 SECONDS REMAINING.TIME-OUT.
YOU CAN IMAGINE, AND GET POOLE
BACK
ONE-POINT LEAD FOR THE SUNS.
WIGGINS GUARDING PAUL, 40 FEETT.
THREE-POINT LEAD FOR THE SUNS Y
>> Dave: BRIDGES MISSED THE
FIRST, BACK FROM WAY POINTS, KN.
R.J. BARRETT, STEPBACK, NO GOODG
UP.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> ANTONIO: UP AGAINST LEBRON.
>> ANTONIO: DeROZAN .
DeMAR DeROZAN  FOR THE
THROW.
HE MISSED IT.
LOOSE BALL.
LOOK AT IT
YOU KNOW HE IS GOOD, BUT WHEN
YOU GET HIM ON YOUR TEAM AND
JACKSON
NO FOULS.
>> ADAM:MARCH FOR DeMAR
DeROZAN.
YOU HAVE TO COME DOWN WITH THE
DE WAY
DOWN.
>> Bill: NO NO.
>> Michelle:
CLIPPERS.
>> Brian: MITCHELL WITH 24 THE
NUMBER.
GOING TO SEE HOW END OF
THREE-POINTER.
AND BACK UP TO A 20
THIRDUND, CHANCE
ON THE LAST SHOT.
RUNN LAY-UP.
JACKSON AND MANN WITH TO GIVE C.
CANARD. SHOTS FROM THE THREE-PO
LINE.
AND YET, TONIGHT, THREE THREE
POINT ATTEMPTS.
TO DO
HOW HE PLAYS IT.
HE IS
MITCHELL.
FOR THE FIRST.
TH25-POINT LEAD,
DOWN TO
THREE POINT GAME. LEAD
HERE.REBOUND.
>> Stan: 11-0 RUN.
HERE IS JACKSON.
JAZZ BACK IN FRONT.
APPROACHING THE  CHANCE.
>> Matt: WILLIAMS.E THREE A
LOSES IT!
WHWHBATTLING!.
NO CALL!
HERE'S GRANT WILLIAMS SHORT.
VANVLEET WITH
RIVERS HAS IT.
MORRIS ON THE DRIBBLELE
AND THEN YOU PLAY OFF A GUY IN
THE CORNER FIVE.
GOT LaMELO.
SEVEN TO SHOOT.
INTO THE